the community of newtown connecticut is
coping with a new tragedy this morning
more than six years after the massacre
at sandy hook elementary school
police say yesterday that jeremy
richmond he's the father of six-year-old
sandy hook victim avielle richmond
apparently took his own life he is the
third person connected to a mass
shooting to die by suicide in the last
10 days
david begna is in newtown outside the
building where richmond ran a mental
health foundation
named for his little girl david good
morning
gail good morning this is so very sad
it's got everyone thinking if there's
somebody in your life who you worry
about daily or even occasionally
pick up the phone today and check on
them or go see them jeremy was found
dead here at the old city hall here in
newtown as you said he ran the
foundation named for his daughter right
here
he did leave a note you know jeremy
actually studied brain
abnormalities and how that led people to
abnormal behavior and in light of his
death experts say
long-term support for victims of trauma
is so
very very important avielle had
a beautiful 250 days in this world after
the death of avielle richmond
her parents jeremy richmond and jennifer
hensel
wanted to channel their grief into
something positive as you can imagine
that turned your world around
quite a bit you feel like the world is
just spinning out of control and you're
going to get spun off if you don't do
something
to grasp onto richmond who was a
neuroscientist
said that he and his wife created the
avielle foundation
to prevent violence and to promote
compassion through brain research
we just need to recognize that the brain
is an organ that can be healthy or
unhealthy
and we need to take care of it on monday
more than six years after his daughter
was murdered at sandy hook elementary
school
richmond apparently took his life
newtown's police chief james viadero
responded to the scene here's an
individual that was an advocate
trying to prevent these type of events
from happening there is some irony there
it's a little unnerving to see it happen
to him we have to recognize what it
means to be
and strive to be humane just last
tuesday richmond spoke about brain
health
at florida atlantic university which is
only about a 20-minute drive from the
town of parkland
two survivors of the school shooting
there died in apparent suicides last
week
psychiatrist victor schwartz if you
notice your loved one or friends
struggling
reach out to them and and get them
connected to the support they need
because it can make a life-saving
difference
the work of the aviel foundation will
continue in fact
we have a link to their foundation on
our website cbsthismorning.com it's on
stories like this gayle where
just reporting the news feels inadequate
we want to do more where we can help so
if you're watching this and you have
thoughts of suicide or you know someone
who does there's a number you can call
there's somebody waiting right now to
talk to you if you need help and gail i
know you have that number
we do david it's so unspeakably sad
thank you so much
the national suicide prevention lifeline
that david just mentioned is open 24
hours a day for anyone needing help that
number
is 1-800-273-8255 we'll also have it on
our website